Explorers opened up the world all around, these fearless men.
They did well in all hemispheres.
Their great audacity made us an offering of the earth.
Yes, these knights, I tell you, have never wavered, the explorers have never weakened.
Nothing can stop them, neither wind nor storm.
These men of heart have no backdrop but a beautiful sky of stars.
The dream of outdoing their fools and without worrying about jealousy.
They sail forward.
Explorers sailed across the oceans.
their navigators bravely, with hearts that were in fact brave, and their little black shells were
really no match for storms. And on the raging waves, their temerity was clearly demonstrated.
Explorers. Always reveal new things to us with beauty. Reject fear. Refuse all fear of adventures
by swearing to return their money and offer the sum to souls. It's good. Do you want a wing or a
thigh? I'll take a drumstick, that'll do just fine. But it's not possible. There's no such thing as a
Maestro, a bird that big. But yes, it does exist. Well, not today, but it still existed two or three
hundred years ago. Where, Maestro? In New Zealand, Australia and some Pacific Islands. Is the Pacific
big? Big, it's enormous. At one-third of the Earth's surface, it's as big as all the other
oceans combined. More than 10,000 islands, kids. Yes, the Pacific is big. And who discovered it?
and when in fact the pacific was already explored more than 4 000 years ago by the polynesians they
were great navigators and it was well before the europeans dear kids there are too many of us on
the island food is scarce and fish are becoming increasingly scarce we need to find new lands
yes that's right you're right grandpa that's what we're going to do we're going to build a big boat
come on everyone will get involved it'll take us five or six moons watch out very carefully higher
higher. A good northerly breeze. Perfect for testing. Come on. It's your turn. Come on. Turn
a little more to the left. Okay. The sail. Works. Nice thing. Very good. Watch out. Now we're going
to turn. Lower the oars to the left. That's a beautiful boat. The most beautiful we've built.
We'll go far with this. And now, we have to lower the sail. So, quickly and be careful. Lower the
sail. Beautiful children. Ah, you're so lucky to be setting off on this. You're going to see a lot
of country. Oh, I didn't learn. Those are some ways. Ah, excuse me, grandpa, I didn't do it on
purpose. It started all by itself, but the stones always start all by themselves. I noticed that a
long time ago. Come on, come on. To see the sky properly, you have to move away from the fires,
otherwise, your path is marked out there. Do you remember? Yes, grandpa, of course. Thanks to the
stars, we will find all directions, whatever the season. We know the flight of migrating birds,
the direction of the wind and also that of the currents. We will find our island.
We have always known that there are islands, many islands far, very far in the direction
of the sun and the wind. Our children leave and do not return, which means that they have
most certainly found the land that suits them. Ah, I would gladly accompany you if I were much
younger. Oh, why not grandpa? You know the stars better than anyone and you would be very useful
to us. Well yes, why not? We will see, we will see. So, we have to get ready. Oh great,
So, we're leaving, we're going to find an island.
But I don't understand why you're not coming.
Without any ado, I'm fine here.
There are plums, bananas, there's everything I need.
I'm not leaving, I've already arrived.
And besides, it's not certain that you'll find your islands.
If we will find them, that's what the old man said.
The old man is never wrong and he's coming with us.
They set off on an adventure, knowing that they would never come back.
Through winds and storms day and night, they kept their course,
hoping to one day or another reach one of the countless islands that dot the Pacific.
Little more to the left. There you go, like that. Come on, kids, lower the oars. That's good.
Straight ahead there. Raise the oars. Look, Dad, the big chickens. We're going to have a feast.
The discoverers of the Pacific, who set off from Asia about 4,000 to 5,000 years ago,
occupied all the habitable islands in this vast expanse. The Solomon Islands, New Caledonia,
Numea, Samoa, Tonga, the Society Islands, Tahiti, the Marquesas, and many others.
In 400 AD, the Polynesians crossed 3,500 kilometers of ocean to settle in Hawaii.
Others went as far as the island of Park, whose statues would be discovered 1,000 years later.
Wow, the Polynesians had come a long way, well before the Portuguese, the Spanish, and perhaps even the Greeks or the Phoenicians.
In any case, when Christopher Columbus set out on his first voyage, he had no idea that the Pacific existed.
He believed that by crossing the Atlantic, he would reach the Indians in China directly.
And even many years later, look at what the world was like as we knew it.
Magellan had already traveled around the world.
Many others would follow, and this map is strange.
And have you seen America there?
Uh, tell me, Maestro, what is this big continent?
That, children, is a land that does not exist.
Almost 2,000 years ago, Ptolemy, the great geographer, had observed that most of the
known lands were in the north, so he thought that there had to be a big continent in the
south to balance the earth, otherwise it would tip over like that.
it would tip over like that. It would tip over because it would be out of balance. At least,
that's what we thought. So we set off in search of this land. First the Spaniards settled here
in Peru under the somewhat chaotic command of Mendana. Forward. Oh yes, yes. Raise the sails
and cast off the moorings. Who is that? He doesn't know anything. But fall, it's Manal,
nephew of the king's target, you understand? Let me do it, okay? Later, I'll teach you.
cast off the anchors raise the anchor set sail for myzen bar at tribor mendana spotted a few islands
but didn't discover anything worthwhile however 30 years later with the pilot kyos this time sir
we're going to discover this famous great continent of the south with you on board we can't miss it
and it seems that it grows gold they spotted a few more islands but no continent kiros was the
one who led the next expedition they were going to go as far as the new hybrids of the pacific islands
but of course, there was no trace of the great southern continent, and for good reason,
because as I told you, it doesn't exist. The Spanish weren't the only ones interested in
the Pacific. A Dutch expedition led by Abel Tasman, who was an excellent sailor, also tried
to find this great southern continent, and Tasman's ship sailed towards the south of Australia.
The sea was rough, there was no way we could go ashore jealously, so we wouldn't plant the flag.
If we had to for the glory of Holland, what should we do then?
We wouldn't swim there, would we?
What do you think?
Well, I was just joking.
Come on, go ahead.
Don't forget the flag.
Well done.
A quick R will warm you up.
The land that Tasman discovered was an island south of Australia called Tasmania.
Next.
Finally, the great southern continent.
No doubt about it, we're there.
We're going to be able to drop anchor.
Oh, T-Man.
After all, Tasmania had just discovered New Zealand.
but he thought it wiser to stay away from it. Yes, come in, but open up, open up.
Take a look at this pretty flower. Ah, I understand. It's to remind me that
I'm forgetting the greatest French explorer, Buenville. I understand, I understand. It's a
Buenville because Buenville was the one who discovered it. Well done. I'm pinning my hopes
on this plant. This Buenville, a man of great talent, was a mathematician, lawyer, elite fencer,
excellent dancer, musketeer to the king and a war hero decorated by Louis X, Louis Antoine.
De Buenville, you gave us a shining example of change and continuity, so I'm making you a knight
of St. Louis. Yes, imagine that the marquise told me that. Ah, you seem bored, young man. I know you,
or at least I know your story. Not very lucky, huh? Oh, why? Well, a few years ago, you assisted
Monom in Canada and then in Quebec, which was besieged by the English. France had already done
little to help you in your fight. Oh, no, shooting, oh, oh, oh. And later, when you came to present to
the court an excellent plan to conquer Carolina and Virginia, where everything had to be done,
the minister, well known for his wars, replied to you with morgue. When the house is on fire,
sir, you don't bother with the stables. Once again, no luck. There was your conquest of the
Malwins, which had to be returned to the Spanish. Finally, have you ever heard of the land of
Australia, Saint-Canognita? Yes, the great continent to the south. Does it really exist?
It's up. To you to answer, Monsieur de Buenville. But to whom do I have the honor, Pierre Antoine?
Verone, astronomer at your service. To serve you aboard your ship, of course. But what ship?
The ship on which you are going to set sail. Set sail? But where? To discover. What? The
mysterious continent. But I'm coming. It seems that a frigate has just been built in Nantes.
The Duke of Choisel, the minister, is a friend. He's going to entrust it to me.
Welcome aboard. Where is Monsieur Commerson, our naturalist? He's not with you. He's getting ready.
He shouldn't be long. Lots of glass and spirits to preserve the samples. Soaps to treat the skins,
tin cans, mastic paper, rolled lead for labels, cork box for insects. Come on Jean, what else do I
need as for me phila bear women are not allowed on board what will become of me without you during
all this time my little jean i'm going to miss you but wait i have an idea you'll see dot perfect
give me your clothes i'll do that now my darling your jean barrett my valala at your service master
goodbye captain bougainville i beg your pardon i heard you were leaving and i wanted to join the
trip with the king's permission. And who are you, Mr. Charles, Prince of Nassau-Segan at your
service? At my service, Prince? Yes, I want to accompany you on your expedition. I am a soldier,
a hunter, a philosopher, a diplomat. I could be useful to you. But Prince, the journey will be
long and very difficult. That's okay. I won't take up much space. So much determination,
it's impossible to refuse. I hope you won't be bored. Bougainville was a man of talent and
knowledge, as Diderot said. He set off on this expedition with all his qualities, philosophy,
courage, vivacity and knowledge too. It was while stopping in Brazil that he discovered this plant
that was called Boonville. In the tropics, it grows very, very quickly. And here too. Then,
Boonville will enter the Strait of Magellan. Two months to cross this damn Strait of Magellan.
Finally, we are in the Pacific Ocean. Are we going to find this new land that we've been
talking about for so long let's continue this little island isn't very welcoming look it's
incredible a sign of peace i think not like our olive branches they're like children with no bad
intentions natural men spared by civilization look oh this is paradise on earth or rather citra
the island where venus goddess of love emerged from the sea so we'll call this island the new
citra. Boudinville, IT. Is the name of this island, is that right? Put up some tents. We're going to
treat our sick. Let's take advantage of their hospitality and the fruits that seem to be
growing in abundance. Higher, higher. I want to have them treated on land. I'd like them to be
able to rest on land for 30 days. Okay, that's good. 15 days will do. Oh, oh my. Oh, but you.
Mr. Verone. What latitude are we at? I won't know until tonight by observing the moon and the
planets. Well, I'll leave you in good company. Look at those breadfruit trees, bananas, and plums.
Look at the little bird eating them. Would make a nice meal for us. What can we buy it with?
Question mark. Nails. These people love nails. You give me your money, I'll give you these nails.
He wants more. That's all I have. You will be judged and punished severely. Believe me, because of you,
these friendly people have become hostile to us. Captain, let me go and talk to them. I've made
friends among them. I'll make them understand that we're not all bad. That can be dangerous.
Trust me. There are good and bad people among men, but we have no bad intentions. Let's stay
friends, will you? There you go. We're new friends. But I have a favor to ask of you.
What can I do for him? To Auto. Herody's younger brother really wants to come to France. Would you
take him? He would be miserable there. These people live in paradise on this island. He doesn't
know what he's waiting for, but he wants it so badly. France, France, it's good that he's coming
with us. Wait, I'm forgetting something. I'll be right back. I'm taking possession of the island
in the name of his most Christian majesty, King Louis X. What do you want me to do? It's tradition.
The Pacific is much larger than we thought. No, no, it would be dishonorable to abuse our strength.
Come on, let's go. Wait, where's Omerson? Hurry up. Ah, it's about time. Oh, you see,
Captain, Jean Barrett is my faithful collaborator.
So, since women are forbidden on board, we thought boys' clothes would suit her so well,
you see?
Of course, Mr. Commerson, I understand, I understand.
You can be proud, Miss Barrett.
You will be the first woman to have circumnavigated the world.
Bouinville narrowly avoided the coral reef that runs along Australia.
He headed north and returned to France via southern Africa.
Bouinville returned more than two years after his departure.
He had discovered dozens of islands, all carefully mapped to allow subsequent explorers to find their way around easily.
It is important to know where you are, but where am I?
Orientation, you understand, is important.
You must always know where you are.
Ah, children, here you are.
I thought you had lost your way because we are getting lost in the invertebrate waters,
but already a great explorer is setting off again for the Pacific and making many discoveries.
Which explorer?
A maestro cook.
James Cook, an Englishman.
And he is said to be the greatest explorer of all time.
But that, children, is another story.
Explorers discovered the world, the round earth.
These innovators will still find ways to trace and then offer them to souls as one offers a beautiful woman to you, to us, to me, I believe.
Oh!